[Musica]
allora ragazzi tecnicamente siamo su
delle flood wars che sarebbero cattura
la bandiera però bello il fatto che non
la persona ecco dobbiamo catturare le
spetta spia aiuto
come funziona siena io non ho capito che
la squadra uno scontro contro stesso
immagino esatto dobbiamo rubare bandiera
al posto tuo
è un po strana ma poi ci prova
spiegarvela però non è colpa mia perché
sarà strana
ok praticamente le bandiere non sono
nelle nostre basi ma sono al centro
della mappa
quindi l'obiettivo è andare a prendere
lì la bandiera e portarlo nella propria
vampa però che si va bene propria base
però da 20 punti e bisogna arrivare a
100 quindi bisogna portare cinque
obiettivi nella propria base
ok è un po strano è un pochino un casino
ai primi mentre puoi sparare alla gente
che tenta di farlo adesso si erano
meglio a dei manichini che penso che mi
spari inoltre non vedo non vedo le
bandiere dove stanno e sono al centro
con la torre gigantesca al centro
ok adesso ho capito lì dentro ci sono
delle guardie e ci sono però anche le
bandiere che però sono le gag ha quindi
non si fa solo tra di noi seafight anche
con esatto
insomma è un casino ma tutti gli altri
obiettivi che si vedono cosa sono
allora alcuni veicoli per muoversi più
in fretta dato che comunque non basta
prendere uno il suo obiettivo essere
anche più veloce ed a volte successive
capitale tripoli
ma già ti ammazzano
no non mi ha ucciso di anomalie sparano
eletto albania sarebbe un baule no che
no e il jack ed è su amano mangiare ho
capito allora questa è la bandiera ha
mai e non ho capito male che male da
solo e che casina c'è della roba che
cosa c'è e cosa ci sia
c'è un altro cespuglio gigante magari ma
che cosa stai parlando
ma chi è questa spa richiesto casi ma
basta la rompo la palla da corrompere
però senza la parola e doveri cosa è
successo e io non lo so ragazzi stava
andando via portando il ciak in base
cerami arrivato un razzo non so da dove
non sono minimamente non sono anche più
dove il ciak sembra rispondono sempre lo
stesso pd giornate che termina al giorno
sempre in balzi mi arrivato un raggio in
faccia non so da chi non so perché
probabilmente qualche sentinella però ma
cosa farà attraverso la porta se ti fa
male a ieri a l'hack è male ma non c'è
già ho preso stesso ma dove sta allora
prendi lo un città dove stefano perso
solo le settimane
scappando so che dire anch'io ne ho
preso uno però non solo per i copri che
si esce di qua non lo so ci dice per cui
lo sparo alleati di 20 punti
c'è uno che sparare razzi lì è immortale
immortale di natale vai bye bye bye bye
bye ma perché sta tenendo nella mia base
marconato masini che la sua fase
database spalle gli spagnoli però vorrei
che quella la nostra è la nostra padri
sbagliato dub step per i ragazzi è la
mia base come ci hai regalato un punto
ma poi scusami non è aumentato nessuno
di 220 punti a perché a tutela dadone le
celebrazioni alla mia base vi siete che
un frigo restia confusi abbiamo portato
la bandiera lui che pirla
la rai abbia sbagliato scusate ho
favorito l'avversario più parti una
bandiera davanti normale che nella
vostra pandev e l'inter parati e infatti
mi sembrava un pò strano allora non si
sa che chi c'era io ce la sto cercando
una maniera molto più tra quelle torna
la nostra che è infatti adesso cercando
di trovare un modo per tornare che un po
strano però vedo se funziona è una
tattica parecchio strana ma potresti
apprezzarla sto scherzando sono morto
macché colonne sono morto sono caduto da
un tubo mag come e perché c'era vabbè i
par cui non mi hanno insegnato niente
ragazzi sono caduto da un tubo da solo
completamente da solo ho perso il già
chi non ci credeva lo giuro agli high
ground pfeiffer e 26 in vivacity dai vai
liberate che mette dieci secondi corri
corri ma non vedete nulla poi da tempo
un tempo ero magari però sto casino e ha
vinto step da solo dai non valete
abbiamo favorito abbiamo giocato anche
le 30 squadre in realtà adesso abbiamo
capito bene madre se per capitoli si già
abbiamo giocato anche noi per la squadra
due non vale ma lo sapevamo
giochiamo per i nostri figli ci fa per
la nostra squadra per favore vai
non so come ho fatto ma dai ero convinto
che andrebbe una parte giusta e io farò
qualcuno mi sa che sta ragazza sta
prendendo sta prendendo dice il
giornalista dove ero perso ma io l'ho
visto uscire qualche ucciso solo fatto
che la mamma mia ragazzi non abbiamo
visto mai
l'avete già preso di nuovo i no no hai
preso in una maniera polizia
io lo vidi dotato e tu secondo lei ha
fatto completamente sparire rese
attraverso l'hack è male ma che schifo
ma non puoi entrare la diverte perché ti
metti a perno e vero c'e ragione però
volevo provarlo maledizione questi morto
ebbene le bandiere in questo gioco bel
no basta spara i pomodori nè scoperta
non si farà smettila
la battaglia sul suo balcone guai
bastava esplosa questi che non serve
malati serve a niente perché tanto non
ci stiamo attaccando le basi
però vogliamo avere viper e viper e
vinciamo da questa va giù stava in due
io ci tengo qui sotto ok ci sono ci sono
lo freddò se possono parlare in base
solo qui sotto c'è più sono mai sparite
magari io tengo lui la corsia verde
dall'altra parte in sezione che c'è lui
c'è sempre ovviamente la mia corsia ma i
corni ma sono riuscito a colpirlo allora
eccolo proprio lui voleva ma il suo
prendi o prendi un premio fair e non c'è
ancora non c'è ancora prendo io prendo
subito penali ok non riesco a
consegnarne una cavolo dai venti minuti
ha tolto il disturbo corretto corretto
con reporter brava brava ha tolto il
disturbo da solo sia uscito va bene ai
fatti sentire
l'hacker male ti ho fatto fatto che
rotola cecchinato incredibile
va bene 40 punti doveva resistere
quattro minuti se riusciamo nascosta si
scrive stata una qui sotto
un mio dio che casino che era nostro
stare dentro col cyber guerra che schifo
e che farà che ti chiamo non ti trovo
pensavo fosse andato dall'altra parte
non è come sempre dietro intagliato
d'italia di un'italianità occhio ma
dietro non rinunceremo mai a un casino
come ragazzi che che che ansia stagione
orribile resistere tre minuti si può
fare
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta dobbiamo correre
la banda a quelli quindi sono le nostre
emozioni nostri io sparò ai nostri soldi
sorry amico mio mi dispiace non voler
mai superman
torna dopo tanto bene non ti preoccupare
importante che stanno bene
red cau ho portato una balia o sono
affatto cagate da quindi iniziato il
video o solo protesta bandiera una però
sono soddisfatto
va benissimo e 60 su 100 come la prima
recuperato che ci fa queste cose che ci
fanno fuori
ma è tipo 2 un ninja che è vissuta nulla
dai niente incredibile e come sauro nel
muore mai però è morta ma non ho capito
qualcosa
le sentinelle che faranno attraverso la
forza perché tu mi hai lasciato basta di
vita quelle sparate perché la forza
coinvolto elevato così foto qua e niente
mi ha fatto fa sentinelli
però preso troppo donna maledetto
maledetto vendute per nulla per mandare
qua non c'è però che ci serve io sto
temporeggiando anche un minuto ma colui
che vola non conosciamo imperato in base
tantissima afferma pancaro fermo a
parlare a ballare potrebbe ma un piccolo
visto cosa ho visto ma se neanche morto
mi stava che finita prima la partita
sarà fantastico quindi ragazzi questo
era capture the flag quindi cattura la
bandiera parliamo anche un po di inglese
oggi ringrazio stefano ravi ammazzato 85
volte e anche a fare però la seconda
fine ho vinta noi la prima abbiamo persa
di poco la seconda abbiamo stravinta se
volete mettere poi boh e vero che
eravamo due contro uno però vabbè dai
dettagli quindi ragazzi speravi
dispiaciuto ringrazio su place man con
software ha partecipato tratto
all'organico descrizione utilizzate il
codice supporto at war che vedete qui e
noi ci rivediamo a un prossimo video
let's go da ragazzi
[Musica]
no